But what I thought I would do,
is I thought I'd take a step
back for us now and I thought
I'd visualize the speakers for
you by help of a trustee
Venn diagram.
Now on the left, we
have bald people.
On the right, we have Pauls.
Colt, firmly in the bald camp.
Professor Irish, firmly
in the Paul.
Me, making up the middle--
the intersection, if you will.
But unfortunately we have Jake
who's thinning up top and
trying to get into bald.
I wish him well.
Now what I wanted to do is I
want to set the scene and I
feel like resetting the scene.
Talking about rendering
performance, there's a lot of
people that kind of go, I'm not
so sure, what does he mean
by rendering, this
performance chat.
And what we've done I think is
we've gone, OK, how long does
this thing take to load?
How many requests am I making?
Have I got gzip switched on?
And what about ETags?
They're dead.
I don't know what to do.
And I think I understand why
we've done it, but the thing
is it's only part
of the picture.
It's only part of the problem.
Because as we discussed with
the-- or Colt discussed with
the memory thing--
that's something that
doesn't fit into
page load time, right?
And that's a part
of performance.
So it's sort of a bit
of a question.
And so what I'm going to do is
just a quick, highly technical
graph, or chart, for myself,
of two apps.
App one is fast to load and slow
to render and app two is
slow to load and
fast to render.
And which is worse?
Which is better?
And the answer, of course, is
both of those are going to
hack off your users.
They are not going to be happy
with you, so it matters.
So what I thought I would then
do is take us through the
pipeline, a little
bit like this.
The idea here is I'm going from
a page load perspective,
because that means we will hit
every part of the pipeline.
I want to get through from how
the browser does a request and
gets pixels onto the screen.
That's actually the job
of the browser.
It's there to get content
on your users' screens.
So it's good to understand it.
And then when your users are
scrolling and dragging stuff
about and just generally using
your site or your app, then
we'll hit parts of this pipeline
again, so it's good
to understand it.
This is part one of two, because
I would normally talk
about the DevTools-y part of
this where you can figure out
how your project is
actually working.
But Paul Irish is going
to actually do
that part later on.
So think of this as a sort
of scene setter, a
part one if you will.
Now, we start off our journey
with the humble get
request, like so.
Our server is going to respond
for us with some HTML--
all pretty awesome.
And the first thing that the
browser is going to do-- and
it does clever stuff with
doing the streamed and
lookaheads and all this
kind of stuff--
but it starts to parse that and
when you look in DevTools
you'll see things
like parse HTML.
Which is this process, really,
of taking tag soup and turning
it into this, which
is the DOM.
And that's the DOM for that
HTML, so we'll just make our
lives a little bit easier and
just call it the DOM.
And then what we do is
we take the CSS--
we're just going to add
that plus in there--
we take the CSS, and some of
that CSS will come part of the
browser as the default style
sheets with the browser,
there's the stuff you put in
line, there's the stuff that's
in your style sheets--
and we start to actually figure
out from the DOM what
CSS applies to what.
And historically, people have
spent quite a lot of time
trying to optimize
CSS selectors.
How quickly--
and it's actually a bit of a
waste of your time because the
browser's very, very,
very fast at
doing selector matching.
So just bear that one in mind.
Anyway, this will show up in
DevTools as Recalculate Style.
So what happens-- and I'm about
to do a sound effect, I
can feel it coming along--
we put these together
like [PBBTH]
that and we get the
render tree.
Paul Irish is happy
with that noise.
He's happy with that.
Now the render tree looks
distinctly like the DOM,
except that things are missing,
like the head, for
example, or our scripts.
They're not there because we're
not going to render
them, so they don't appear
in that tree.
But let's say, for example, I
decide that in my style sheets
I'm going to put section p.
[BOOP]
I'm going to say display none.
That will disappear from the
render tree because it's set
to display none.
It's not something we're
going to draw.
It's not something
we care about.
Equally, I could have a pseudo
element and that would add
something into the
render tree.
So the render tree as I said, it
looks like the DOM but it's
not the DOM.
It's the styles applied
to the DOM.
So that's that.
Now the next job-- and it's
going to look like a really
simple job-- we've
got all this CSS
that we want to apply.
And it's basically like widths
and heights, and display blog,
position absolute, all
this kind of stuff.
And what the browser has to do
is take that and go, where
does everything live
on screen?
What are the boxes here?
And, as you probably know,
this can actually get
extremely expensive because
everything tends to be
contingent on everything else.
So if I were to change the
height of body, everything
that's inside body needs
to be recalculated.
And this will show itself up
in DevTools as layout.
And that's where all those
boxes are coming from.
Good.
So the next job that we
have is to actually
fill in some pixels.
We know where those boxes are,
but they now need filling in
with pixels, so we need
a rasterizer.
Now just a bit of terminology
in case you don't spend the
time looking at this stuff.
Vectors are basically shapes
that we have the mathematical
formulae for or we have the
positions of the corners, for
example, in the case
of a triangle.
We're interested in
actually pixels.
So what we actually have to do
is we have to figure out from
our triangle which pixels we
need to fill in and what color
they need to be.
And this is the process
of converting
vector to raster, OK?
All pretty simple.
Now if you and I were to have a
fun afternoon and we were to
create a rasterizer, we'd
probably include
methods like this.
And I know that we would because
these are the ones
from Chrome's rasterizer,
which is called Skia.
And so you can imagine that
I'd drawPoints, drawOvals,
drawRectangles, drawBitmaps,
draw some text.
And if you've worked with the
HTML5 canvas, a lot of this
stuff will actually look
quite similar.
It's the rasterizer,
basically.
So now what we can do--
I actually ran that HTML--
I actually ran it through Skia
and said, what did you do?
And it told me.
So I thought I'd show
you what it does.
Ta-daa!
But you probably didn't see
what was going on, so why
don't we have ourselves
an instant replay?
Now, you'll see that as we get
through each of these calls
we're starting to build up
the picture of what's
actually going on.
Draw a rounded rectangle, which
isn't that clear but
that's the drop shadow.
Draw the path, here we go, draw
the bitmap, which is my
face, do a bit of tidy up,
and we'll call it a day.
DevTools is going to show
you that as paint.
That's how it goes about letting
you know that it did
some of that work.
Now, some of this bears
a little bit
more scrutiny, I think.
Specifically, drawBitmap.
Now, I was a good developer.
I sent through my tiny JPEG, I
compressed it, I'm good on the
page load time, I'm happy,
well done me.
But you'll notice that it's
called drawBitmap and not
drawJpeg, or drawPng,
or drawGif--
"jif," gif.
Hands up for gif--
ooh it's going to be close--
hands up for "jif."
You're wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
They're not "jraphics",
are they?
So now we have our JPEG and we
basically go through and we're
going to decode out an
image into a bitmap--
red, green, blue, and
possibly alpha.
But the thing is we are also
maybe doing a bit of
responsive web design, so we
also have to do some re-sizes
as well on the other side.
So these are extremely
expensive.
They show up in DevTools--
you can spin down Paint records
and you'll see image
decodes and image re-sizes--
and they will kill your frames
per second if you have them,
particularly re-sizes
actually.
OK, so we've spent some
time with drawBitmap.
The next thing we want to
look at is quite fancy.
We're going to do a
bit of animation.
What we're going to actually end
up doing is we're going to
move that picture of
me up to there.
Now when this happens, we
basically took this rectangle
around everything and said, this
is now damaged and dirty.
This area needs fixing.
This needs repainting.
So we actually have to step
through one by one and re-run
all those commands, with the
drop shadow, and the white
box, and the bitmap.
And it doesn't take much
imagination to figure out that
if we have a lot of things that
need painting, or we move
something a really, really
long way, that could be a
hugely expensive thing
that we just did.
So what we do to work around
that is we do these things
called layers.
Instead of having one surface
that we render into, that we
rasterize into, we
have several.
So this is my website and
this is actually--
the masthead thing
is a canvas--
so why don't we just boost
that out a little bit.
Now what happens is, we can
basically do this so that when
we want to change something in
the masthead, we don't have to
worry about repainting
the thing behind.
We keep it separate.
This is extremely useful.
What's also interesting about
this, or at least to me
because I'm a nerd, is the Next
and Previous buttons are
actually DOM elements
on their own, right?
But they're sitting on top of
something that was just
boosted out to its own layer.
So what Chrome actually ends
up doing, is it ends up
creating more layers
just for those.
So you actually end up with
four of the suckers.
And these all get sent across
the GPU, which we'll talk
about in a second, and then
composite layers is what
you're going to see
in DevTools.
That's when it's taking all
these layers and all this
stuff and it's basically
going [SHOOP]
putting them all
together again.
Figuring out what layers it
needs, where they need to
live, all that kind of stuff.
So those are the layers.
They're pretty cool.
And you might be asking
yourself, so
how do I get a layer?
That's exciting to me.
You'll notice it's subject
to change because it's an
implementation detail.
But all the same, let's
have a look at them.
3D or perspective transform--
anybody use an old
transform hack?
Anybody translateZ(0) happy?
Yeah?
Work for you?
Good, OK that's the
classic one.
Video elements, canvas elements,
composited plugins
like Flash or Silverlight,
an animation on opacity,
interesting--
transform, filters like blur and
all those ones, and then
the last one, which are my Next
and Previous buttons,
those are rendered on top
of another layer.
So those are the ones, you could
imagine that we might
add some more, we might.
So the last little part--
and this is the
website from tonight--
is to actually take those
rastered images and send them
across the GPU.
The thing to bear in mind, all
that rasterization we did was
done actually on the CPU.
And when we do rasterization--
this is a small detail, I just
wanted to include it for
completeness' sake--
we actually rasterize
into tiles.
Doesn't make any difference to
us as developers, but I just
like to include it.
So there we go.
That doesn't matter for what
we do, but we have the CPU.
All this work so far has
happened on the CPU.
So when people are talking about
hardware accelerated
this and that, so far
everything we've
done was on the CPU.
The last thing that we actually
end up doing at this
point is sending those tiles
across to the GPU--
happy days.
And that was a nice simple
animation, but the bandwidth
between CPU and GPU might
be quite constrained.
Especially on a mobile device,
it's very easy to
saturate that link.
And if you're having
to send across--
if you're doing a lot of
repainting, and you're sending
a lot of stuff across
to the GPU, you
might really struggle.
So it's a finely
balanced thing.
Anyway, that's going to show
up as composite layers.
And finally, [WHOOSH]
there we go, we end up with
something on screen.
So now we know how you get from
the humble get request
all the way through to some
pixels on screen.
So with that said, I am now
interested in the bit where we
control the workload.
I really want to ask, are you
the captain of your ship?
Arrr.
But I'm not going to.
But we are, and so seeing as
we're in control, let's talk
about some millisecond
stuff for a second.
Let's frame what we're
interested in.
When a user interacts with your
site or your application,
we have 100 milliseconds in
which to respond for that user
to feel like it was an
instant response.
If we take more than 100
milliseconds to respond to the
user's interaction,
we have failed.
They will notice.
The second thing that we care
about is 16 milliseconds.
If we're doing anything like
scrolling, or dragging, or
anything that's regularly
animating and updating the
screen, we have 16 milliseconds
in which to get
all the work done.
So this is just to frame
our argument here.
Response time, 100 milliseconds,
frame time, 16
milliseconds.
Now all I'm going to do at this
point-- as I say normally
I'd show you some DevTools,
but I'm going to just talk
about some stuff you want to
look at, some stuff you need
to be careful of, and then Paul
will actually run you
through DevTools and the tools
that are available to you.
Small style changes can have
big layout knock-ons.
If you're, say, changing body
like I explained before, we
have to re-layout everything.
Huge deal if you're trying
to do that in an
animation, for example.
You decide you're going to
change some high level element
instead of one or two
levels into the DOM.
Everything's probably going
to get recalculated.
That will kill you in terms
of your frame rate.
This is something of a common
misconception that layout is
somehow always triggered
by JavaScript.
It's not.
You can have a transition that's
in response to a hover.
It's not done by JavaScript, but
it's layouts all the same.
And layout isn't painting.
Now that you've been through
that pipeline with me, again
there's often a misunderstanding
that layout
is somehow painting, but
actually layout--
if you do change the position
of something, we
might need to repaint.
And we'll have a look
at something that's
doing that in a second.
There's a thing that looks
a little bit like
this and the code--
it doesn't really matter too
much what the code is doing.
I'll tell you what it's doing
anyway, just for a laugh.
We're going through some
paragraphs and we've got some
other element we want to match
the widths of all our
paragraphs to.
So the first thing we do is we
ask for the width of this
thing called greenBlock.
And we ask for its offset width,
which causes Chrome--
and in fact any WebKit or
Blink-based browser--
to go off and do a layout
operation, go, what's the
width of the green
block please?
And then we set the first
paragraph's width.
And then we go through that loop
over and over and over
and over and over again and
that is effectively
read-write-read-
write-read-write
-read-write-read-write--
and that's not a good thing.
Because every single write
invalidates the previous read.
This is called layout
thrashing.
You do not want this in
your applications.
What you wanted to do--
there we go--
was to ask for the width once.
Read-write-write
-write-write-write.
Happy days.
Paint--
I'll show you this demo.
There's this brilliant tool
called Show paint rectangles.
If you're ever wondering whether
something's painting
in Chrome, that is your tool.
And what's going to happen is so
I select some text, right,
and you get this red
box around it.
And that's basically Chrome
saying, I had to do some
repainting here, Paul.
Thanks, Chrome.
I expected you to do
it and you did.
You are so reliable.
Anyway, so what I've got is I've
got these buttons-- oh,
yeah, scroll bar, that's getting
repainted-- now I've
got this button up here
that says Animate.
It is a highly realistic
animation.
Now the interesting thing here
is that this one big area
needed repainting because we're
moving everything inside.
But we can also figure out
that they've all been
flattened down to one surface,
one layer that we're actually
painting into, right?
So this is the thing that's
getting invalidated.
It needs repainting.
That might be slow, so
we're quite smart.
What we want to do is we're
going to use the translateZ(0)
hack to isolate all those boxes
and all we're doing is
moving them around.
And the GPU is really good at
just moving stuff around.
It's fantastic at it.
So we're going to do that.
There we go.
Change it to black just
so it's a bit easier.
And then moving you see we're
not painting anymore.
Because we painted them once,
all these layers, and then we
just asked the GPU to
move them around.
This is an awesome way of using
the translateZ(0) hack.
I've come full circle.
I used to hate it, now I love
it just for this reason.
The danger that we then have--
I'm just hovering
over in this--
animate the radii.
Now these boxes have a slightly
rounded corner.
What I've got is I've got an
animation queued up that's
going to change the border
radius of each of those boxes.
Ready?
[AUGH]
Look how much it crawls.
So it's not always a good thing
to isolate everything
and put a translateZ(0)
hack on it.
Because you can end up creating
a lot of extra work.
If you end up having to paint
each one of these things,
these all need re-rasterizing
and then they all need copying
over to the GPU.
Eww should be what you feel.
So this tool is amazing when
you want to figure out is
something getting repainted,
what's getting repainted,
switch on that tool, have
a look at what goes red.
If you see a big red flash
across your whole screen,
you've probably got
a problem, OK?
So that's a good way
to find that out.
So painting, avoid it.
You can't avoid it on the first
time your page loads,
but you want to try
after that.
You can promote elements
to isolate them.
If you have one element that
is moving around and maybe
does need repainting, promoting
it is actually often
a really good way to just make
sure that nothing else has to
be repainted unnecessarily.
But bear in mind that it can
also spawn other layers like I
showed with the Next and
Previous buttons.
You just want to be
careful with it.
Layers themselves do actually
have a knock-on effect for
memory, the management, and the
transfers I've mentioned.
So just be careful with that.
Often people say, well, how
many layers can I have?
And there isn't a good answer to
that because it depends on
the device that you're talking
about and whatever else you're
actually trying to do.
So you just profile it and see
if you can see how your frames
per second is doing and respond
to that, really.
Paint storms-- we were debating
this term earlier,
what it really means.
What it really comes down to
is you wouldn't want to be
caught in an actual storm, you
don't want to be caught in a
paint storm, either.
It's generally you're
doing paint that you
shouldn't be doing.
You're either painting too much
or you're painting too
often, all those
kind of things.
It's just a nice name for saying
it's not what you want.
You're doing too much paint,
so don't do that.
Interestingly, because the GPU
is exceptionally good at these
things particularly, they often
don't cause paints.
If you isolate an element and
then monkey around with it's
opacity and transforms,
we won't be repainted.
Like those boxes, they
didn't repaint.
Happy days, we all smiled
a happy smile.
Image decodes and re-sizes,
those are done on demand.
So when we're rasterizing we
hit one of those drawBitmap
calls, we actually queue up
the decodes and re-sizes.
So it can make for very
sporadic frame
rates, let's call it.
Because we do it on demand.
So when something comes into
view that we need to
rasterize, we go and get the
image, we decode it, which
could kill us, and for all
intents and purposes that's
not a good thing.
So bear in mind that handling
images is expensive.
You can't really avoid images
on the web, but just bear in
mind that handling them is
expensive so you want to see
if you can mitigate it.
And one of the best ways to
do that is actually avoid
resizing them when you can.
And I say that frustratedly
because responsive web design
is, a, popular and
b, quite cool.
But it does put a really heavy
tax on the browser.
So if you're going to do it,
just know that there's a tax
and be happy to pay the tax.
There you go.
Now requesting an animation
frame, if you've
not come across it.
When you are changing things on
screen, please avoid these.
They are not timed to the
browser's refresh cycle.
So they will just run whatever
suits, and that could be at
the worst possible time
for the browser.
What you want to do is
use friendly green
requestAnimationFrame.
It is so helpful.
Anybody use jQuery?
Yeah?
Anybody use jQuery animate?
OK.
It currently uses
set interval.
I would love that to change,
in fact I actually double
checked that from the
jQuery source.
It does use set interval.
There are patches that you can
apply, then switch it back to
requestAnimationFrame.
Simple enough thing to do and it
might be worth it for your
project if you are using
jQuery animate
as it stands today.
Scrolling performance is a
big, big deal actually,
because most of the time people
scroll on the web.
Apparently it happens
quite a lot.
Scrolling then, it does cause
paints because as content
becomes visible we have to
rasterize, we have to paint
that stuff.
So we want to make sure
that when we do it
we keep things light.
The easiest thing to do with
scrolling is to avoid doing
anything in scrolling.
There's a really good one
actually that you might want
to look at, which is--
it doesn't take too much
imagination-- if you're
scrolling through and you
trigger a hover on an element
as you're scrolling, then we
have to repaint the thing that
you hovered.
Then you keep scrolling, and you
hover out and we have to
repaint the thing that you now
hovered out, just because you
were scrolling past it.
OK, now if your hover effects
are really expensive, that's
going to be awful.
What you want to do is you want
to basically switch off
anything changing.
So you basically add a class
or something that basically
switches off hover effects
while you're scrolling.
Wait a little bit of time then
switch them back on again.
Happy days.
There's a HTML5 Rocks article
about that, that I wrote.
Pretty good.
I mean the idea is good,
it wasn't my idea, I
just wrote it up.
Anyway, debounce scroll
handlers.
What do you possibly
mean, Paul?
I mean this.
If you add a scroll listener to
your window, in this case,
don't do anything inside
that scroll handler.
Please, for the love of all that
is decent, don't do it.
What you do, store the value if
you need to, great, super,
and then schedule a
requestAnimationFrame to
handle the scroll--
the thing that happened.
Because you can get 5, 10, 20
of these events, but really
you probably only want one.
You want the last one most
likely to know the current
scroll position because you're
doing the parallax site.
Just because it's cool doesn't
mean it's right.
Just throw that out there
if anybody's listening.
OK, the last thing I want to do,
because we're running low
on time, is to just do a little
bit of myth busting.
JavaScript--
and you'll notice I haven't
talked about it at all.
You maybe thought
I would, right?
Because when we're not talking
about page load time we're
talking about JavaScript and how
slow it is, and horrible.
But it's not, actually.
Work is often triggered
by your JavaScript.
You maybe change a class with
dot classname or classlist or
something, or whatever.
It's often triggered by
JavaScript but the work that's
actually running is often
carried out in C++.
Layout is not done
in JavaScript.
Layout is done in C++,
it's done lower down.
So bear that in mind.
And slow JavaScript is this
kind of idea that, oh
JavaScript is slow and that's
why the mobile web is slow.
No, it's not actually the
reason most of the time.
Because it's not JavaScript
that's actually running.
It's the other stuff that's
inside the browser that's
actually running.
Unless you're making
a game, or--
there are classes of
applications that do rely on
JavaScript quite heavily.
I do want to say that I'd like
you to start treating
JavaScript benchmarks with deep,
unyielding cynicism.
Because JavaScript probably
isn't your bottleneck.
Layout probably is
your bottleneck.
Paint is probably
So if you start seeing it's
really fast with JavaScript--
yay, so.
And then the other thing
is the DOM is slow.
You hear this one quite a lot
for fairly similar reasons to
the last, actually.
Interacting with the
DOM is actually
quite fast, as it happens.
The problem is that changes to
the DOM probably incur changes
that are layout, or recalc
style, layout, paint,
composite, misery.
So be careful.
Now, going forth, aim for
60 frames a second.
It is well and truly
achievable.
You control the browser's
workload.
You are in fact the
ship's captain.
I brought it in.
Performance is a feature,
it is not a unit test.
It's not something you get to
the end of the project--
am I fast?
No--
ship anyway.
Nobody'll notice.
Wait until they complain,
that's what we'll do.
No, think of it, put
it on the list.
It might be two, three,
four, but make
sure it's on the list.
Ideally put it number one.
I do, oh I love that.
Profile, and then fix.
A lot of times you'll read
things that are like, this is
fast, do this.
And that's fine.
Sometimes you need to do that.
But you end up writing things
that don't fix the problem
you've got.
You end up writing something
that makes paint better, but
you've got a layout problem.
Profile, use DevTools, Paul
will show you how.
Profile your stuff, figure out
where you're actually slow,
then fix that thing.
Sounds simple enough,
because it is.
Profile early, profile often.
Smile a happy smile.
Do it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]